Vincent Lindon
pour connaître sans connaître qui vient
pas souvent alors continuons lui fait la
fête à Vincent
en tous les cas merci d'avoir choisi
tout le monde en parle pour parler de
votre nouveau film d'autant plus que
c'est un film important pour vous
c'est une question non non c'est pas une
question c'est mieux constatation c'est
un film important pour vous c'est un
film détienne chatillaise qui s'appelle
la confiance règne avec vous Cécile de
France Cédric berger et Anne Brochet
alors je fais le pitch allez le pitch
c'est l'aventure de deux domestiques
Cécile de France et vous deux primaires
voire de primates de neuneu deux idiots
de crétins quoi qui bossent chez des
bourgeois et qui se casse en courant en
piquant ce qu'ils peuvent emporter voilà
ça c'est leur vie quotidienne mais
au-delà de ça il s'aime et nous
spectateurs ont fini par les aimer voilà
c'est c'est des animaux mais ils sont
plus humain que nous des fois un peu
comme bataille à Fontaine un peu
c'est ça non c'est oui c'est un peu ça
c'est des ils sont ils sont proches de
l'animalité mais derrière il y a une
grosse humanité ils sont très libres
voilà ils font ils font ce qu'ils disent
ils disent qu'ils font ils pensent
qu'ils disent ils disent qu'ils pensent
ils ont des rapports de couple entre que
à mon avis peu de gens ont
qui tourne pas leur langue cette fois
dans la bouche avant de parler et rien
n'est prémédité ils font quand ils
veulent ils décident pas de voler c'est
parce que ça marche à la vue comme ça
c'est absolument rien il y a un autre
pitch on pourrait dire aussi que c'est
deux descendants des groseilles qui sont
domestiques chez les Le Quesnoy voilà
c'est plus si on veut faire référence au
grand succès de châtailler la vie est un
long fleuve tranquille on pourrait dire
ça exactement
chez eux choisissent si c'est fatigué
vous tapez un et si c'est un peu c'est
pas compliqué
alors la confiance règne parce qu'avant
de se rencontrer il ne faisait confiance
à personne et maintenant il s'aime et la
confiance règne en fait c'est là que ça
vient oui enfin c'est l'expression c'est
quand on dit la confiance règne c'est
que justement elle règne passe et comme
quelqu'un m'a dit on m'a raconté un truc
l'autre jour j'ai trouvé vachement bien
une expression c'est quand il y a un
doute il y a pas de doute c'est à peu
près pareil c'est un peu la même chose
voilà c'est une antiphrase
c'est un truc de de
rhétorique oh là là mais non c'est quand
tu dis des trucs intelligents je les
coupe pas systématiquement alors vous
êtes né le 15 juillet 59 à Bologne quel
souvenir vous avez de votre naissance
Vincent alors Vincent dans le film elle
le domine elle le trompe d'ailleurs elle
lui dit et cette phrase formidable et
lui dit c'est pas parce que on travaille
ensemble qu'on dort ensemble qu'on baise
ensemble qu'on est ensemble
elle est marrante elle est marrante et
lui c'est un peu on peut dire un débile
léger quoi c'est un débile léger c'est
l'expression médicale exactement que
c'est c'est il est ni bête c'est c'est
pas un crétin c'est c'est il est il est
impulsif et c'est quand le niveau de
l'intelligence réagit à la vue c'est
quand on ne pense à rien avant de faire
les choses et qu'on ne pense rien après
les avoir fait c'est quand on les pense
au moment présent
c'est une espèce de Bourvil tu vois ce
que je veux dire et moi il me fait
penser à Nino monfredy dans nous nous
sommes tenter mais de de des torrescolas
pour vous c'est extraordinaire c'est un
rôle difficile quand même c'est une mise
en danger extraordinaire non ouais c'est
un rôle difficile mais en même temps en
plus je suis assez inquiet parce que
chaque fois ça m'est assez difficile de
voir des extraits ou de voir le film
comme un acteur on dit qu'il est souvent
à l'écran en tout cas 50%
à la ville il y a forcément des choses
de moi qui sont dans ce rôle donc c'est
assez effrayant vous êtes passé de
l'autre côté de l'écran là cette fois
non vous faites plus attention à rien
quand on voit votre gueule sur les
affiches on se dit là ça y est tu as
gardé des séquelles de ton rôle attends
je vais je vais d'abord répondre à Terry
parce qu'il va faire allez-y
après je m'occupe de toi
non c'est très gentil mais c'est vrai
que un rôle comme ça la question je me
suis posée le travail que j'ai essayé de
faire c'est qu'il faut l'incarner si
c'est pour essayer de marquer une
distance d'avoir ce qu'on appelle c'est
ce petit message subliminal avec la
salle en voulant expliquer chaque fois
qu'on joue que soit moi Vincent je suis
plus intelligent que le personnage et
que j'en pense pas moins c'est pas la
peine de le faire je veux dire que c'est
comme au tennis si vous attaquez pas la
balle c'est le qui vous attaque si on
attaque pas un rôle et qu'on rentre pas
dedans c'est lui qui vous submerge donc
ce rôle là le gros travail ça a été
d'accepter ne serait-ce que l'affiche
bon je suis dans toute mariée avec une
tête ingérable vous auriez pu vous y
opposer la fiche non
oui j'aurais pu mais ça aurait été idiot
ça aurait ça aurait été ça aurait été
une mauvaise idée il aurait fallu pas
faire le rôle mais pardon où je fais le
rôle tous en Suisse pour faire un débile
léger en même temps le choix était pas
énorme bien alors donc châtièse elle est
facile elle ne fait pas de mal en plus
Vincent est un acteur qui s'implique
énormément qui est d'une précision
époustouflante alors c'est important
quand même pour vous cette
reconnaissance professionnelle parce que
vous aviez quand même une revanche à
prendre sur la vie parce que vous avez
une famille extrêmement brillante
Vincent Lindon est toujours vous êtes
senti un petit peu dans votre
adolescence en position peu
d'infériorité vous avez un petit peu le
syndrome Michel Drucker c'est que Michel
Drucker c'est quelqu'un qui a eu une
famille très brillante son père médecin
ses frères qui ont fait des grandes
écoles et tout et lui il avait besoin de
prouver que que voilà qu'il était
vachement bien aussi il le prouve encore
tous les dimanches alors j'ai une
famille haut de gamme alors votre père
tu vois la famille de l'indon à votre
père Laurent industrielle dans les
autoradios il a gagné beaucoup d'argent
après il s'est retiré dans le dans le
Berry votre mère Alix du fort bon on la
connaît bien c'est une grande
journaliste et qui était à Marie-Claire
descendant d'un ministre de la Troisième
République ensuite elle a épousée Pierre
Bénichou directeur
donc voilà ça a quand même Pierre
Bénichou d'ailleurs conseil la pièce de
Laurent Ruquier dans laquelle il juge
pas si vous l'avez vu il s'appelle gros
chaleur est excellent donc ça c'est
votre beau-père Pierre Bénichou votre
grand-père ben c'est Raymond Raymond
Lindon au Magistra à la Cour de
cassation
l'arrière-grand-mère paternelle c'est la
sœur c'est la sœur d'André Citroën quand
même pas rien votre oncle Jérôme édition
de minuit éditeur de robe grillée du
Nouveau Roman vous avez lu les mémoires
de la femme d'Europe grillée là non
parce que la femme d'Europe grillée sort
ses mémoires et elle raconte dans ses
mémoires que que son mari Robbe-Grillet
donc il va bientôt rentrer à l'Académie
quand ils étaient jeunes ils avaient des
meurs un peu libres quoi donc il l'a
prêté à des copains il faisait des plans
à trois etc et ce qu'on apprend en
lisant le bouquin je vous le dis c'est
que votre oncle Jérôme il en croquée
c'est-à-dire que Jérôme Lindon le patron
des éditions de Minuit qui est quand
même un des plus grands éditeurs
français un des plus sérieux il se
tapait la femme de robe grillée de robe
grille mais c'est ça que j'aime pas avec
le journaliste c'est ça qui m'embête je
mets pas la précision dans le
journaliste non
j'adore le fait que vous ayez des fiches
incroyablement précis c'est la première
fois qu'on se trompe jamais d'habitude
on dit que Jérôme et mon père ceci que
cela mais ça fait penser à une histoire
de Jack Nicholson qui a vu dans la
presse qu'il avait appris au Festival de
Cannes quand il avait fait Easy Rider et
tout d'un coup il est devenu une star il
a appris que sa sœur était sa mère et sa
mère et sa grand-mère et là je viens
d'apprendre quand même que mon oncle
donc en croquettes avec la femme noire
voilà j'aurais pu m'en passer mais bon
je le sais voilà donc ça m'allait bien
jusqu'à présent je le savais pas non
mais quand on connaît Jérôme Lindon qui
est quand même très respectable et tout
savoir qui faisait des plans à trois
avec robe briller sa femme c'est quand
même fort non c'est fort voilà alors
donc ça c'était le tonton mais comme
j'ai dit quand même famille assez haut
de gamme quand même chez chez les chez
les lindons vraiment et puis des études
courtes ce qui est pas le cas dans ce
genre de famille alors vous avez fait un
bac c'est bon ensuite
prépare Sup de Co vous restez 22 jours
quand même pas le bout du monde non plus
Jérôme bon et Vincent par exemple
ah j'ai eu attendez il y a sa femme non
parce que il y a quand même ça veuve qui
qui regarde la télévision
j'y peux rien c'est c'est le bouquin il
est sorti ça maintenant c'est fait hein
c'est n'était pas au courant là elle va
le savoir dessus donc après au bout de
22 jours de suite de cours vous plaquez
vos études pour devenir aide costumier
vous avez commencé en bas est-ce
costumier sur le tournage de Mon oncle
d'Amérique en fait vous étiez chauffeur
de la camionnette de costume de Gérard
Depardieu
en 80 Pierre Bénichou votre beau-père
vous trouve un job de Roady sur la
tournée de Coluche ça a duré 9 mois puis
après vous partez aux USA vous avez la
chance d'avoir de la famille un oncle
producteur de musique à New York une
ferme dans le Texas vous rentrez en
France vous travaillez au Matin de Paris
toujours grâce à Bénichou tu as beaucoup
de pistons quand même hein
beaucoup de cinéma là effectivement ça
doit rien à personne quoi c'est vous
quoi le premier film Le Faucon de Paul
boujena avec Huster vous êtes allés
c'est moi tout seul c'est une
coïncidence c'est pas vraiment moi en
plus c'est un peu de la chance c'est
parce qu'il est arrivé au cours Florent
et il a demandé où était Francis Huster
je l'ai pris immédiatement pour
échouraquis ce qu'il a fait très plaisir
et que il est surtout resté en arrêt
devant moi parce qu'il a trouvé que
j'avais énormément de tiques avant qu'on
en parle et que je reçois une vanne de
Laurent aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
j'en ai que deux ou trois à la minute et
qu'avant j'en avais 5 à 6000 j'en ai
beaucoup plus à la minute oui donc
c'était étonnant quoi il est rentré il a
vu un type qui bougeait la tête comme un
fou et il s'est dit il a demandé à il a
dit kiki qui est ce mec dans dans le
dans le couloir du coup j'ai été le voir
un casting et je suis tombé en face de
de d'un copain de Huster qui s'appelle
Yves Lemoigne et qui lui aussi a des
tiques et donc je suis trop en face de
lui dans le bureau et il a cru que je me
moquais de lui parce que je faisais
comme ça aussi c'est pas simple voilà et
donc il a il s'est énervé il a très mal
pris il m'a viré du bureau et j'ai passé
une demi-heure à l'expliquer donc ce qui
est quand même le comble j'ai dit mais
non je suis aussi anormal que toi
génétique je suis malade ce qui nous a
rapproché et donc j'ai fait le film les
mecs qu'on éthique c'est des
francs-maçons tu sais
pourquoi il a des tiques
c'est depuis le divorce de ses parents
ah oui c'est quand Laurent Alix se sont
séparés
quand même
non c'est ça
va aller mieux
prendre le temps de pleurer ou pas non
on enchaîne alors vas-y
tout le monde la connaît la grande
carrière de Vincent Lindon au cinéma
engrenage la drogue la prostitution
voilà les filles les filles aussi les
filles aussi vous avez des filles quand
même très célèbres sans Lindon Caroline
de Monaco c'est parti
je veux pas qu'on en parle bien sûr j'ai
dit voilà c'est parti voilà
point Claude Chirac c'est vrai ou c'est
pas vrai
non Laurent et puis Sandrine qui a été
votre épouse il est
[Musique]
alors Vincent comme votre film s'appelle
la confiance règne on va faire une
interview la confiance règne
[Musique]
est-ce que vous faites confiance à votre
copine quand elle est seule en soirée
oui dans tous les cas dans tous les cas
parce que tant pis pour elle c'est son
problème est-ce que vous faites
confiance à Gérard Darmon pour pas
draguer votre copine
ouais
j'ai réfléchi un peu quand même
non mais c'est parce que j'ai des est-ce
que vous faites confiance quand une
fille vous dit qu'elle a jamais vu un
mec comme vous
ah c'est bien c'est une bonne question
ça
en plus j'ai envie en tout cas oui
bah oui ça m'arrange vous faites
confiance à votre maman quand elle vous
dit que vous êtes formidable
non ouais je fais confiance à ma maman
sauf quand elle me dit qu'elle me trouve
formidable très bien faites confiance à
Raffarin pour sortir le pays de la crise
non faites confiance à l'information du
journal de 20 heures de TF1
pas oui enfin c'est ce qu'on appelle les
amis il y a des émissions donc je fais
confiance dans ce qu'on me dit mais j'ai
pas confiance en tout ce qu'on me dit
pas faites confiance à la Star Academy
pour trouver les chanteurs de demain non
vous faites confiance c'est un
journaliste qui vous promet bien entendu
tout ça c'est Vincent oui j'ai envie
mais c'est toujours le même problème
c'est que je pars du principe que c'est
son problème c'est tant pis pour lui il
sentira plus mal de s'apercevoir qu'il
m'a trahi que moi n'apercevoir que je me
suis fait travailler c'est pas un
problème je m'arrange avec ça moi c'est
plus emmerdant de vivre avec l'idée
qu'on a fait quelque chose et qu'on a
pas tenu sa parole que ça fait soi-même
gruger d'accord je pense que l'honnêteté
la meilleure des combines mais je te
trouve plus zen qu'il y a quelques
années où tu aurais pu comme tout le
monde j'ai j'ai mûri comme tout le monde
alors vous faites confiance à Patrick
Bruel quand il vous propose une partie
de poker juste pour s'amuser ouais j'ai
encore fait confiance à deux jours et
alors vous avez perdu combien non j'ai
gagné ah mais lui aussi ah d'accord vous
avez trouvé deux pigeons voilà
la police quand elle vous dit qu'elle
est là pour vous protéger
mais elle vous dit jamais ça la police
elle vous attrape elle vous attrape mais
quand elle est là pour protéger elle est
pas là vous faites confiance aux hommes
pour qu'un jour la paix soit enfin
possible dans ce monde
c'est pas les hommes qui vont y arriver
ça va être une circonstance déjà plus
déjà plus
je dis pas que des conneries
non mais c'est vrai c'est gentil tu as
beaucoup de talents
qu'on supporte c'est jamais bête bien
sûr pourquoi tu veux partir après parce
que j'aime bien venir une émission et
après partir j'aime pas rester des
heures
quand même mais j'aime pas rester parce
que je je pars en je fais attention à
moi je me regarde je suis filmé tout ça
me fatigue ce que j'aime bien dans la
vie au départ c'est me faire du bien
quoi enfin depuis très longtemps mais
j'aime bien être dans un endroit où je
me dis ça ça me va donc ça ne va plus de
partir que de rester donc je vais partir
je réponds pas mal à ma fille est-ce que
vous faites confiance à un mec qui vous
propose du shit dans une boîte non
d'abord j'en prends plus mais non ça
c'est un truc où j'ai pas confiance
parce que j'ai ce syndrome j'ai toujours
j'ai pas confiance quand on m'offre
quelque chose à manger ou à fumer dans
un endroit bizarre de quelqu'un que je
connais pas parce que j'ai tellement
peur de partir dans un flip atroce ou
d'un coup on met mis un truc surtout
donc ça me non j'ai pas confiance
avec des cadeaux j'aime pas recevoir des
petits cadeaux de de fans ou un truc une
petite peluche pas cher
je sais pas d'où ça vient je jeûner
ta confiance là déjà plus non non mais
j'ai eu un problème avec ce qui a porté
quoi avant j'aime bien les trucs neufs
est-ce que vous faites confiance est-ce
que je me fais confiance oui alors là
j'ai une théorie qui est très simple je
vais essayer de d'expliquer très
rapidement si par hasard on on décide
que je dois traverser une rive
et qu'on met une pierre par exemple un
caillou
on met une pierre toutes les trois
mètres et que l'écartement de mes jambes
et de deux mètres 80 je ne suis pas sûr
de moi je ne sais pas comment je vais
aller d'une pierre à l'autre mais le
problème d'aller de l'autre côté de la
rive nous ne pose aucun souci je sais
que je vais y aller donc j'ai assez
confiance en moi je ne suis pas sûr de
moi ce qui n'est pas du tout la même
chose je me dis je vais à peu près
arriver à une zone à 15 mètres près de
là où je voulais aller quoi non
merci
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu